les modes d'exploitation des ressources
ça c'est le choix essentiel bon est-ce
que on va exploiter des ressources pour
les ramener sur la terre ça c'est quand
même peu probable donc effectivement les
questions c'est si vous faites un
habitat lunaire et même une base
semi-automatique ben effectivement va
falloir essayer de récupérer le maximum
de ressources in situ parce que vous
allez pas tout monter de la terre c'est
évident pour les astéroïdes là c'est
différent forêt les astéroïdes et
exploiter les ressources des astéroïdes
ça ça pourrait peut-être être plus vu
comme éventuellement ramener sur terre
mais c'est quand même tout un débat la
question de la vocation commerciale que
vous évoquiez est-ce que il y a un
marché où sont les acheteurs où sont les
producteurs quels sont l'organisation de
ces flux entre ces localisations et ça
montant que je grave sont des sujets que
je ne traite pas mais qui me paraissent
particulièrement important cette
question cette idée d'une économie
orbitale qu'est-ce qu'elle recouvre je
crois que là puisque vous faites de la
prospective vraiment le sujet de
l'économie orbitale c'est certainement
un des très beau sujet à traiter et puis
dans le cas des acteurs quelle est la
part de la puissance publique par
rapport aux acteurs privés ce que nous
savons tous que ces acteurs privés aux
États-Unis sont partis sur la base de
financement public et c'est absolument
pas de l'argent c'est pas seulement leur
argent c'est aussi leur argent mais pas
seulement leur argent enfin la question
des utilisateurs non autonomes dont une
certaine façon l'Europe fait partie
aujourd'hui puisque nous n'avons pas
fait le choix de faire voler nous-mêmes
et revenir sur Terre nos propres
astronautes